we're making Double Stuffed sheet pan
pizza topped with my secret ingredient
honey don't knock it till you try it
we'll start by rolling out some dough
and we'll place that on a half baking
sheet add mozzarella to that top with
more dough take string cheese and we'll
frame that around the entire thing fold
the dough over the edges crimp the sides
and brush with olive oil bake this for
about 20 minutes then add sauce more
cheese soap Bretta and put that back in
the oven for about 10 to 15 more minutes
I like to add basil and it's time for
that honey I talked about earlier this
might be the cheesiest thing I've ever
made and I've made some very cheesy
jokes M I'm going to give this four out
of five stars and I finish
it